hey guys uh thank you for taking the
time to sit down with me I want to
introduce you reduce everybody to the
two of you Ben and Matt you are both
PJ's pararescue jumpers with the the air
force and for those unfamiliar with what
PJ's do PJ's are you know they're
they're basically Rambo paramedics who
jump into enemy territory if necessary
to rescue downed pilots and and help
with other things as well people rescue
people and but you were you were combat
medics on steroids is that is the set a
fair assessment yeah that's a very nice
way of putting it but I'll take it thank
you
so let me tell you guys how this all
started a friend of mine her
sister-in-law is an ER doc in New Jersey
and as we do with our friends and our
family we text them and say how are you
doing I'm gonna read you her response
this is her exact text back to her to
her sister-in-law my days are filled
with fear sadness despair helplessness
and death it's unreal it's like a
nightmare it's shocking like you cannot
catch your breath because someone else
is dying or critically ill and you have
no time to acknowledge and process
what's happening around you or even no
time to fully exhale it's draining
emotionally and physically even on my
day off I'm stressed out about the next
shift and exposing my family to the harm
through me I feel like I'm just holding
my breath and I can't exhale
all I do is shallow breathing when I
heard this my heart sank and I started
to realize that what those on the front
line are dealing with and have been
dealing with is nothing like they've
ever experienced before both in the
amount of death that they're seeing and
in the pace of operations and it
occurred to me that it's much more like
combat medicine that it is like civilian
medicine and so I figured as a way to
try and help those on the frontlines who
dealing with this and who had dealt with
this and we know that there are mental
health struggles that go along with this
kind of pace to reach out to people who
are much more familiar with what combat
medicine looks like and feels like with
the hope that we can give them something
some coping systems mechanisms so I
guess that's a good place to start one
of the things I also know that I started
to learn about civilian medicine is that
asking for help is really a sign of
weakness and most of them believe that
you show strength and you just muscle
through it you stay mission focused and
the there seems to be a lack of
resources they've never been taught how
to deal with the trauma that that many
of them are suffering so I guess my
first question is is is it the same in
the military as a different military
how are you taught to how you trained to
deal with that insane pace of both death
and stuff that you might be dealing with
around you
it starts off I think for us is uh
starts in the pipeline so our training
is extremely stressful and definitely
trains your mind to address things in
situations like that and we know in the
civilian world unfortunately that's not
how it is you go to college you go to
nursing med school and kind of get
thrown to the wolves at that point but
we're lucky enough to have all this
training but it comes to when you out of
that training and it's real life finding
your group of people if it's your
teammates if it's fellow doctors and
nurses and people going through the same
thing a lot of times you can find a lot
of comfort in them because you can
relate to them that's what I think I use
and Ben may use the same thing but
that's something that is extremely
useful for us
yeah go ahead sorry yeah it's just a
level of trust you have in your
teammates like to the pipeline
definitely builds upon that you with
people who've gone through some two
years before you can go out and start
practicing your trade that's a little
different but when we do deploy everyone
has their kind of coping mechanisms and
like for me it's being able to talk to
my teammates like if I see something
terrible or I do something that's like
little psychologically jarring
I won't go call my family not because I
don't trust them just because they won't
understand who I'm going through and I
kind of had that when I was a paramedic
school like with significant other
didn't understand that the trauma of
like death and experiencing it on the
regular and so when you have it like a
team so you really trust that you're
meshed with real tight it's easy to go
talk to anyone it's not to be the whole
team it can be someone that you trust in
the team so when you get along with and
I think that we always on our team have
a very good understanding that it's okay
to show weakness and say hey man I'm
having a really difficult time right now
even if it's like a family matter League
and what their divorce or if it's in
combat like hey man like I need to call
you like a little frazzled after this
last man we talked about it and like
it's okay because everyone I think they
want to be invincible but that's not
possible everyone has fear everyone
feels that you're human after all and so
once you acknowledge that being able to
let down your wall a little bit somebody
and talk about it in a realistic manner
is more helpful than just kind of
stowing away because it's really easy
just go in your room after like an
operation and just sit there like
listening to music listen like music
make you depressed sometimes it's sad
lyrics a little time you know pops over
like yeah pop so easy to isolate I don't
think that's the healthiest way to deal
with it they dealt with stuff like that
and then I found it's better to go talk
to people you're in a community for sure
can you dispel a myth you know I think
people in in the civilian world think
that the military that you
compartmentalize your emotions your
mission focus you do your thing and and
like you don't like what the question is
you know the military knows that you're
gonna have to deal with that at some
point and what have you learned
is it better to wait until you get back
home when the emotions flood in and then
you seek the help or oh you're supposed
to seek the hell
all the time throughout throughout the
process it depends so yeah I I've done
both and my last deployment Afghanistan
I think was better for me because after
everything happened I would talk to
somebody immediately about what happened
I wouldn't say like necessarily how I
was feeling I was describe the situation
at least so someone else I could just
talk to them about it like and that
helped me a lot and yeah I don't think
it's healthy to just let it build up
obviously during the mission you're not
gonna just start getting emotional I of
course that's casualty for example or
something of that nature you just do the
most good you can for most people and
people will die you understand that as
long as you get the preparation mindset
I think is most important so you go into
the situation understanding that you
can't save everyone or that people will
die it's just the nature of the beast
and then when you come out of it give
yourself a little breather time relax I
like to always take notes almost a
journal when I'm done with something
just so I can remember it fully because
your mind will alter what happened
you know if it's like a few days after
so I like to have that for me my
personal thing just like how I actually
felt after it and then I will go tell
somebody what happened and then as the
day's progressed we're feeling kind of
weird about it I'd always have someone I
can call usually it's a teammate not
necessarily a psychological counselor
until they're hopeful like when you get
back home station but why not when we're
out like deployed it's definitely just a
team member that we talk to you so Matt
what skills are you taught or have you
developed how because your medics your
combat medics you're not psychologists
and psychiatrists and yet as Ben's
explaining you're you're going to each
other and asking for help what what
skills have you learned when somebody
says to you I'm hurting I'm struggling
today what do you do when somebody does
that well the thing is I think during
deployments like every situation is so
dynamic that none of them relate there's
definitely aspects that do relate but
for the the general general thing it's
always different so I think a huge thing
of talking to one another is you just
need to be a good listener let them talk
it all out a lot of times that's all
they really need is just to talk it all
out and then I try to minimize what I
say to them
cuz they they know what happened and
they they're just using me as an outlet
and I'm happy to be that outlet and
again like we're no professionals and we
usually just kind of listen and talk and
then kind of advise them like hey if you
need to go to a professional like we can
get that for you but sometimes just
talking about it just again what Ben
said is talking to someone you trust
that's just that's a huge thing that can
relieve a lot of stress and and I think
that's something we can relate to with
the civilian medicine because it is in
that ER room we've been in a few of them
it's a team team dynamic every time they
go into a shift that's that's a tool
they can definitely use the thing that
hurts me when I hear about it is that
the culture has developed in civilian
hospitals that asking for help is a sign
of weakness how do you teach people to
that it that it that it takes like that
is that it's the opposite that strength
comes from asking for help like how how
did you learn that I mean you came into
the military it's all the machismo and
bravado you know to learn that you can
cry and ask for help is actually the
right thing and the strong thing to do
you know did you have a did either of
you have sort of a moment that you sort
of like a light bulb went off you're
like that's not gonna work for me I
think there's been times that something
has an event has happened and a lot of
times I would kind of replay that event
and see what I could have done better
and what I could have fixed and
something that I used was in the
military you can talk to people who have
a little more years on in this career
field and I'm talking to them and seeing
what they how they coped with it and how
they learned and how how they attack
that problem I definitely took a lot out
of that with talking to people who have
dealt with it and how they cope with it
and using those techniques and skills
and applying it to myself
I think grief and dealing with stress
like that it's always changing it's
never the same and you always got to fix
your coping techniques because you're
always going to be in a different spot
next time I come around that that
problem is going to be a different part
of my life and different
aspects and priorities that I'm gonna
have to face so again it's going to be
hard to kind of push through that wall
but I think a lot of people are aware of
themselves where it's like you know I I
do need some help and we just need to
get the message out that you know
talking about what happened is not a
sign of weakness and ask we're gonna
help is yeah like you said more of a
show more strength and weakness okay one
of the questions I got when I asked I
asked doctors and nurses and other
frontline medical staff and first
responders to please send some questions
knowing that I was gonna be talking to
you one of the questions a few of the
questions I got all dealt with feeling
overwhelmed how to deal with how to
control the feeling of I can't keep up
or I'm drowning and it's not just
necessarily work it's also financial
problems that are now showing up and the
horrible stress of I am I gonna hurt
infect my family you know how how do you
deal with the feeling of being
overwhelmed how do you bring that down
well personally it's I can't I don't
want to pretend to understand
everybody's plight because I'm not them
but for me what's worked for me I'm not
saying we're lost and we got toddlers
too is just one step at a time so like
whatever your target is just bring it
back a little bit so she's thinking
about eight things of course you get
overwhelmed and can't be at once you
can't multitask you minds it's not
capable of it so what we do is we just
hey what's the feed to bring back what
two things he can't you what one thing
can you accomplish then you do that move
to the next and that's the best way to
deal with it because if you start trying
to just think about everything that's
coming down on you yeah you're gonna try
yourselves quickly for us it's like
called one of your target or just you
know go one foot at a time one foot
forward just that's what it takes to get
through it then you can look forward
further after that if you kind of figure
it out
great advice so to make the list smaller
when one foot in front of the other I'm
gonna share a question here I got from
from a police officer my Police Agency
in California lost an officer to cook at
19 last week what advice do you have to
show other officers on the front line
that we and management support them and
understand the risks they are placing
themselves and their families and this
is a great great question you know how
do leaders respond when they're not on
the frontlines to show that they
actually do care about the people who
are who are we're facing the danger
every day I think you can just start off
the leadership in that position can
definitely you need to show definitely
compassion towards them of hey you know
what like a brother Anonymous's has
passed away especially during this
pandemic and and just reach out a hand
definitely don't lose contact with the
below the men who aren't in the ranking
spot but reaching out and showing
compassion and and offering help I think
is going to be a huge goal for them to
do letting people be an outlet because
again people are probably going to keep
it inside and then that's when mistakes
are happened when they really shouldn't
be happening so is there um can you
obviously you've had senior folks come
down and check in on you guys is there a
way to start that conversation is there
is there other things that can be said
that make you shy away and feel
different genuine and there are things
that actually draw you in or is any
effort well received yeah I can feel
patronizing at times know that like if
someone comes up to you after
something's happened and his leadership
is kind of like oh they're just showing
up now I think you have to start that
leadership before this kind of stuff
happens I think this is an
organizational thing where if you're an
organization that doesn't put people
first and they certainly when I start
doing that your people will find it
disingenuous if you've always been in an
organization that has your people's
backs that uh you know like this is
simple things like when we have someone
who has a newborn we all get diapers for
them just out of our own pockets not
necessarily we have to it's going to
want to
because it's a leadership philosophy
like hey then people matter people are
more important than making money for the
organization or completing you know X Y
& Z so I think if you your organization
isn't there you should start focusing
that and if it is already there just
kind of focus that kind of that lands
like hey we're here to help the people
because the people matter for our
organization here's how we're going to
do it you know providing services for
them you know made time off they need it
stuff like that here's an interesting
question which is when how does somebody
speak up for themselves
this one says how do I speak up up up
some up for myself not just during this
pandemic but but outside of that as well
how do you how do you I've been trying
to be the leader I wish I had for my
co-workers but but I'm struggling
because of my direct supervisor haven't
hasn't once come to our area to witness
for herself what we're doing and asking
how we're doing so somebody who may be
leadership isn't there for them they
want to fill that role huh any advice I
think they would need to obviously if
they're kind of caught in the middle
with a direct supervisor over them but
they're still supervising other people
you have to be the rock for the people
underneath you yeah and really be there
for them but if you're a supervisor to
other people it you need to make it your
your due diligence to go to that higher
supervisor and be like hey we are
struggling and including myself and we
need your help
or we need you to do something and enact
for us because it's going to be tough
for them but you got to remember what
that why you're in that supervisor
position and that's because you have the
skills to represent other people to hire
leadership so passing that up is
something that can be scary but
something that needs to be done and
remembering why you're in that position
may help you do that I had a couple
questions about compartmentalizing
emotion you know twelve hours on twelve
hours off you know how to how to use the
twelve hours off to to heal a little bit
but also you know people who are
suffering extreme stress at work how to
avoid bringing it
home and one of the questions was I'm
learning to compartmentalize so I don't
stress out at home but then the question
is is when when to deal with it so the
question is you know how do you deal
with the the trauma at while also
protecting your family from from from
what you're going through and I don't
mean you know necessarily transferring
the virus but just just the the high
stress that you trying not to bring home
it's important to have a family and
significant others understand because
compartmentalizing only goes so far
I did that coming back from deployment
and then I had like a breakdown on
vacation my family and they clearly
compartmentalizing didn't work it only
goes so long before it's all gonna come
out as like a steaming kettle so you
have you have to at some point you don't
to give them everything right that's
because it's not all or nothing but
maybe try to explain some of it because
their significant others they do care
you know at least I hope they do and
being able to at least as give them
snippets that they'll understand kind of
broken down not everything don't look
like I saw like this me get bodies but
like hey I dealt with this today and
it's affecting me emotionally if I'm off
a little bit I'm sorry but I just want
you to understand that I still love you
I think that's the best way to deal with
it cuz I didn't do that and I had to do
that explanation and it's almost selfish
to keep it to yourself and not try to
share it I I love that that it's to feel
like you you don't want to burden your
family is actually a selfish disposition
they love you they care about you give
them the honor to take care of you and
as you said you know for those who
understand what you're going through to
report out all the detail because they
understand and to do a clarification for
family but you still get that reporting
out I think I'm finding that very
interesting the need to just not
necessarily unload how you feel but just
simply reporting the facts of what I
dealt with is is part of the the coping
it sounds like absolutely you know the
in some cases you know in some states
and many hospitals who have been
overwhelmed the pace is slowing down but
one of the things that I've been made
aware of by
by friends in the military is that
sometimes the calm is more dangerous
than the storm and I've heard stories of
folks who come back from combat and
sometimes months later the motion the
emotion floods in because they haven't
dealt with it and because they've been
so mission mission mission focus that
when when it's all quiet and people
don't understand because rationally
everything's fine you're home you're not
in combat anymore you you know where's
all this coming from
are there some thoughts that you can
share if the pace is slowing down for
some of our frontline medical staff what
they can prepare themselves for if this
flood of emotion shows up what to do
when it shows up will it show up very
curious as to your experiences and your
and your and your thoughts I think
something that is very similar between
our job and the civilians is that like
you said it's there so mission focus for
months on end and now as it slows down
they start to get relieved and kind of
come off that mission focus and the
hardest part I think for me as well as
coming back to the US and people are
around you that have no idea what just
happened for your last four to five
months while they are just living their
normal lives and and you've just gone
from a complete 180 of this combat high
stress environments and now back to
normal life and people don't know and
can't relate most people can't relate to
what you've just gone through so in the
civilian world again it's all ramped up
and now you're kind of coming off and
you're going back to your family and you
know people who weren't in the ers and
never got infected they just are mad
that they're stuck in their house right
so it will come I don't think it's
definitely inevitable that they would
they will come with these emotions but
you need to remember that what your
mission was of hey I chose to treat
these people and chose to be in this
career field and and remember that
mission and remember that not everyone
can do that job so when you do get
frustrated if these people are just
complaining about being home when you
start seeing all these terrible things
remember why you're in that position
because these guys can't really handle
it as much as you can
that's fantastic been any thoughts on on
how they can mentally prepare for the
flood of emotion that is very very very
likely gonna gonna hit them at some
point when this is when the last thing
slowed down yeah like Matt said it's
easy to get angry at people I everyone
catch some stuff like man these peoples
don't understand like we've been through
like they're out here just living the
life getting drunk all the time or you
know whatever and it's not fair to do
that to other people because like we
said you do need you because you have
the ability to it maybe they don't so
you're not better than them you're just
you and just take that and then when the
emotions do hit I think it's best not to
be alone I like to find other people I
can hang out with if they're gonna hit
or at least call it's easier to be
around a person I think
and then they don't resort to like
substances like alcohol it doesn't help
us it's easier just to find like a hobby
like push to energy to something we like
to use working out it's it's easy it's
free so that's what I was find a hobby
so this is very interesting that because
the trauma is an energy buildup and it's
it's letting the energy out I guess it's
it's it's kind of the physical
comparison to talking right which is to
somehow vent the steam I guess yeah I
think a lot less alive you know working
on watches something like whatever like
kind of fine detail or there's a lot of
mental brainpower it's kind of a nice
thing to just the case your mind - I -
what about what about burnout you know
there's a huge fear now that a lot of
doctors and nurses and other frontline
medical staff and first responders
because the pace has been so high that
they're gonna burn out drop out of the
professional together and the fear is is
that if we have a resurgence we actually
won't have enough people to cope that
we're gonna actually have a dip in in
medical staff I
I'm gonna guess that it's the same you
that there's gonna be a repeating
pattern here to the answer which is a
good thing but what how do we prevent
burnout because these are you know we
keep calling them essential workers you
know you said at issue I think it comes
from both the individual and leadership
so the hospital in general needs to
figure out how to treat these people
fairly for and compensate them for the
time they put in then a lot it will even
in our profession sometimes you go
through a lot of stuff and this ask ask
ask but you feel like they never give
you your time back and I think if any
gesture that's giving time back whether
it's you know compensation of wages or
just actual time off which is hard to
give sometimes but you know allowing
that is helpful for people don't want to
stay in that career field hmm for the
individual when you have time relaxed
you better you better take advantage of
like find out how to relax don't be will
they don't know how to relax
mmm I wish I could change them by sister
thing you gotta figure out your own you
know like some people like to have tea
before they go to bed you the whole
ritual if that's you gotta do that's
what you gotta do you know finding what
is able to actually let your body relax
not just sit there and ruminate or sit
there just like waiting to relax because
it's something you gotta it's truly
something gonna work on a similar
meditation just you know mind I guess
this is another sort of thing that could
so many will have to deal with which is
right now the the we're we call them
heroes every day and many of them we're
clapping them to go to work that's gonna
end and they're just gonna go back to
being doctors and nurses and and and
frontline medical staff again you know
the person right now who's cleaning
hospital rooms is like the most
important person in the world right now
and they're just gonna be go back to
being just the person who cleans the
room you know how there's gonna be an
identity issue I imagine will you go
from being a hero to just being a doctor
or nurse or or somebody working in a
hospital or first responder again you
know that has to affect somebody yeah I
think it needs to have self reflection
of why you joined in the first place and
not joining the military but join that
that occupation no one predicted that
this pandemic was going to come and I'm
gonna be a doctor so when a pandemic
hits I'm going to be able to be the hero
right
taking that that stress off once the
starts ramping down and taking that
relaxation and really really embracing
it and then still of self-reflection of
you know what you're thankful for and
and how you will be thankful for those
slow days when you go back to the ER and
understanding again like why I became a
doctor was not to treat people in the
pandemic well I will do that and I am
thankful to do that but I'm also here to
just be a doctor on the day to day basis
and not be a hero I'm here to just help
people so just remembering that will
will pay dividends here's a question
that was a that came in
what are aspects of combat medic culture
and what skills and practices of
frontline medics direct leaders to hold
up to hold each other up the most how is
their culture of leadership and
interpersonal training different from
and maybe even better prepared for
crisis than the rest of the medical
culture so I guess it's a it's a nice
broad question which is what is it about
the combat medicine and your profession
and military life that makes you
actually better equipped than civilian
hospitals in civilian medicine medical
culture to deal with these kinds of
things
I think a huge thing is just the mindset
alone training to prepare for the worst
is what we do and when that worst day
comes then we know what to do and
mentally we know how to attack it and we
practice our skills so many times that
physically it's it's this second nature
but that mental battle is where I think
we make make the most money between the
two two groups having that attack
pattern of hey I know this is going to
come one day and I know like I am
capable of addressing these things I
think that's what makes a difference
they have a day-to-day same thing in the
ER you know multiple patience and
everything goes well sometimes it goes
bad but this flip of a switch now
everything is going extremely bad is is
where it might be biting them in the
butt of hey we weren't mentally prepared
to take on this many patients and see
this much death and despair when I think
the military does a really good job of
mentally training their soldiers so when
that day comes we know we know how to
act mmm yeah the amount of training we
get definitely it speaks to performing
because when you're kind of in the
fight-or-flight mode and you're not able
to process and think like you normally
would so it all comes back down to what
you were taught and how you react to it
so the amount of training we go through
I mean think about it we do over two and
a half years of training before we even
get to actually touch a real patient so
we have that's where it's unfair almost
for us because we have so much
preparation and mindset training like
hey Jesus how it's going to happen and
the training is usually like a lot more
difficult than the patient you're gonna
get like it's missing every single limb
you're just blood spurting everywhere
like it's not quite as bad as you think
and so I think that's where we kind of
benefit is I know this in my experience
the stuff we've done is yeah it was
pretty bad sometimes but I can handle
more yeah yeah guys thank you so much i
I can't I'm so grateful any any final
words of advice that you'd like to that
you'd like to share especially for some
of those who maybe haven't dealt with
the trauma yet any any final thoughts
that
or words of advice one in part I think
just be thankful for being safe and
healthy and and understand why you're
doing this mission for for the whole
country and in the world and definitely
the better days will come and you got to
make sure you're not afraid to reach out
for help it doesn't show a sign of
weakness and continue to push forward
because this will all go away and we
will go back to our normal lives and and
we'll be all happy people again you know
then yeah I think as you have the right
mentor that you get the most amount of
good with late good and that it's okay
to feel the way you do it's you're not
weird or abnormal for which I'm sad
feeling like almost lost or broken that
everyone goes through it that's okay
like you're allowed to have that feeling
that's human and just be glad you can
feel that feeling instead of just not
feeling anything which is much worse I
think so go on go and embrace those
feelings and talk about them because
that's healthy it's part of being human
that's magical you know one of the
things I've learned from spending time
with folks like you is is never cry
alone and if the emotions overwhelm you
then go find someone you know or and if
you see someone who's in a corner go put
your hand on their back you know guys
thank you so much I can't thank you
enough and thank you for the work that
you do I really appreciate it
[Music]
you